hamburg hat die wahl andreas wunn im
gespräch mit den spitzen kandidatinnen
und kandidaten der hamburger
bürgerschaft sei wir machen pläne und
setzen sie um
wir wollen nicht unseren bundesvorstand
hier haben der uns gar nicht erklären
kann was in hamburg zu tun ist hier
arbeiten ganz konsequent daran dass in
unserer stadt alle gut leben und das
leben vor allem auch sich leisten können
im kern geht es um die frage ob hamburg
auf 47 millionen euro steuern verzichtet
hat zugunsten der warburg-bank olaf
scholz der damals bürgermeister war
spielt dort eine rolle es gab gespräche
es ist nicht so ganz klar
sie waren finanzsenator daher die frage
was haben sie wann gewusst
ich darf ja zu konkreten steuerfällen
nicht sagen sonst mache ich mich
strafbar
ich kann aber klipp und klar sagen es
gibt in hamburg keinen politischen
einfluss auf entscheidungen der
finanzämter
ich habe auch persönlich mit keinem
vertreter der warburg-bank über ihre
steuerangelegenheiten gesprochen
[Musik]
das thema klima und umweltschutz ist
teil unserer dna
wir müssen vor allem die autos aus der
innenstadt bekommen um die stadt den
menschen zurückzugeben
wir sind die partei die auf visionen für
die zukunft der stadt setzt sie haben
eine idee davon wie sich die stadt
weiterentwickelt
das war ja lange und es wirkte zumindest
so alles eitel sonnenschein zwischen der
spd und den grünen im wahlkampf hat man
jetzt den eindruck der erste
bürgermeister und sie haben härtere
bandagen angezogen mancher fragt sich
wie glaubwürdig ist dass das eine und
das andere
ich finde das muss funktionieren wir
haben jetzt fünf jahre gezeigt dass wir
erfolgreich und in weiten teilen auch
geräuschlos zusammen regieren und jetzt
geben wir hamburg aber eine echte wahl
unterschiedliche persönlichkeiten
unterschiedliche politikstil aber auch
ein anderes inhaltliches angebot wir
haben eine sehr viel stärkere
zukunftsorientierung wie idee davon wie
sich die stadt in der zukunft entwickeln
soll
bei der spd geht vieles auch weiter so
und ich finde das ist doch ein
großartiges angebot an die demokratie ja
zu sagen ihr habt eine echte wahl jetzt
mal die partei das land in den fokus
setzen und nicht die eigenen
persönlichen eitelkeiten der pnv man
steht im stau
er kommt zu spät für zu teuer und das
ist wenn der metropole wie hamburg nicht
hinnehmbar keine koalitionsgespräche
ausschließe war in der stadt kann ich
nicht eröffnete ausschließeritis
irgendwie verbreiten sondern ich muss
sagen was denn das was die geschichte
die wir gemeinsam erzählen was es denn
der geist den wir für hamburg den
nächsten jahren damit die menschen
entwickeln wollen die cdu hat ja auch
einen eigenen vorschlag für ein
klimaschutzkonzept vorgelegt
warum eigentlich es gibt gerade erneut
beschlossenes gesetz von rot-grün
klimaschutzgesetz was passt ihnen da
nicht was gerade verabschiedeten wäre
das also scheinen hätte er mehr
buchstaben als sein also wenn ich diese
busse anschaffen wenn ich bäume
weggeräumt und wenn ich es nicht schaffe
die die vorgaben zu erfüllen
da muss man ernsthaft fragen ist das
eigentlich ist ernst gemeint sondern
macht oder also sozusagen motorik und
man schiebt wollten und wir haben klar
gesagt diese stadt muss sich verändern
aber dann bitte nachhaltig und ernsthaft
und in absprache mit den
verantwortlichen mit der industrie mit
der wirtschaft die haben ja ein
interesse am klimaschutz
für uns heißt eine klima wende eben auch
eine verkehrswende ich glaube auch dass
viele autofahrerinnen und autofahrer
auch gerne mit dem öpnv fahren würden
wenn der eben kostengünstiger wäre und
wenn wir die möglichkeit hätten ihnen
auch zu erweitern wir haben die
situation dass wir festgestellt haben
dass viele sozialpolitische themen die
uns wirklich am herzen liegen und
wichtig sind eben momentan mit der spd
und mit den grünen nicht umsetzt rasen
[Musik]
sie fordern als einzige partei hier in
hamburg die mieten deckel ähnlich wie in
berlin
kritiker sagen das bringt nichts da
werden weniger wohnungen gebaut
vermieter stecken kein geld mehr in ihre
häuser was soll ihrer meinung nach der
mieten decke bringen der mieten decke
bedeutet dass fünf jahre lang eben die
mieten bei bestandswohnungen nicht mehr
steigen dürfen
eine mietobergrenze ist da auch mit in
dem gesetz von rot rot grün beschlossen
wurde
das bedeutet dann eben auch konkret dass
die menschen erst einmal eine
erleichterung haben so in hamburg haben
wir die situation dass die mieten in den
letzten jahren um 21 prozent gestiegen
sind so da würden wir erst mal sagen da
gibt es einen stopp
[Musik]
wir sind auch für fahrradverkehr auch
für die stärke des öpnv
aber wir möchten keinen zwang ausüben
auf autofahrer
es geht uns darum den autofahrer nicht
länger zu diskreditieren
in sachen duktus habitus gestus ist der
hecke nicht unbedingt mein fall
[Musik]
man hat so das gefühl dass die afd
sehr häufig auch hier in hamburg auf die
themen kriminalität und migration setzt
die spielenden hamburg für die
hamburgerinnen und hamburger keine große
rolle die kriminalität nimmt ab sind sie
auch deshalb so schwach weil die afd
sonst nicht viel anzubieten hat also
schwach ist die fdp mit 4,5 prozent wir
mit jedem mit sieben prozent bestimmt
nicht schwach wir haben unser ergebnis
jahr gesteigert im verhältnis zur
letzten wahl
das thema kriminalität bewegt unsere
wähler und ich bin dazu da dass wir die
politik für unsere wähler auch machen
wir haben immer noch über 210.000
straftaten in hamburg ist ein staat der
wirklich den anspruch hat seine bürger
zu sichern oder zu schützen
er gibt sich mit 210.000 straftaten
nicht zufrieden wir sind für an
fließenden verkehr wir wollen auch dass
autofahrer irgendwann umsteigen können
aber dazu braucht erstmal die
voraussetzung
nachhaltigkeit ist gut diese
wegwerfgesellschaft ist verkehrt der
mieten decke ist für uns deswegen nicht
akzeptabel weil er die vorstufe zu
enteignungen ist
[Musik]
sie sind sehr viel gegen etwas also
gegen fahrverbote gegen die stadtbahn
gegen das 365 tage ticket gegen radwege
auf hauptverkehrsstraßen wofür sind sie
denn wie wollen sie das verkehrschaos
hier in hamburg in den griff bekommen
also alles was sie jetzt aufgezählt habt
wird ja des verkehrschaos nicht lösen
und wenn man gegen etwas das kann man ja
nicht gleich zu sagen man hätte keine
vorschläge
ich finde gerade die letzten neun jahre
haben ja bewiesen dass die spd eben uns
in startnummer eins geführt hat und da
muss man halt auch gegen viele sachen
sein dass das erste und das zweite ist
dass ich glaube wir hätten lange weil
die stadt eben wächst eine pv ausbau
gebraucht